so this house is perfect
for viewing the olympics um it's 10
minutes from the stadium
tracy northcott was expecting this
airbnb listing to bring in more than 30
thousand dollars during the olympics
we've got two tvs you can sit down and
watch the olympics that was the idea
but the games in tokyo are underway and
her ambitious plan to rent out this home
and about
20 others during the event have been a
bust my properties are completely empty
nothing zero a ban of foreign spectators
due to the pandemic has taken a toll on
reservations
around 34 000 nights in tokyo have been
booked in airbnb
during the games just compare that to
the 200 000 nights booked in rio during
the 2016 olympics
airbnb is proud to partner with the
olympic and paralympic games
and that's also a disappointment for
airbnb which made a big bet on the
olympics
when it became the games official
accommodation partner
airbnb was anticipating that this would
give them really some major brand
credibility and awareness
airbnb is hoping that its sponsorship
investment will still pay off during
future olympic events
for hosts who are fully independent from
the app the priority is pairing losses
and the tokyo games are highlighting the
risks of investing heavily in short-term
accommodation
northcott moved to japan from australia
more than 20 years ago as a software
engineer
in the past few years using her own
funds and taking out a mortgage
she became a full-time airbnb host this
house is a
you know it's a lovely classic japanese
home it's not easy being an airbnb host
in japan
the country has some of the strictest
regulations on short-term rentals in the
world
according to hospitality industry
analysts to host guests
northcott had to set up a proper company
pay two thousand dollars in licensing
fees per house
and outfit some places with professional
alarms and safety systems
similar to ones used in hotels she was
expecting a surge in demand during the
tokyo olympics
similar to the one of the rio games when
airbnb listings revenue
increased by about two thousand five
hundred percent compared with regular
times
by the end of 2019 we were completely
booked we were planning
on making around about 500 000 us
dollars
analysts say increasing the number of
airbnb accommodations can actually help
cities like tokyo
to avoid building too many hotels in
preparation for the games
airbnb is an interesting proposition for
something like the olympics
macra and modi studies the hospitality
industry at boston university
the olympics in general have been called
into question by many destinations just
because of
the amount of money and infrastructure
that is typically required to host the
olympics
new hotels and accommodations are
usually built leading up to the games
and modi says airbnb provides another
option use homes that are already
available
with airbnb you don't really have to
create accommodation that will then just
remain
unused after the olympics are done
airbnb's partnership deal with the
international olympic committee is
estimated to be worth 500 million
dollars according to analysts
now studies say the city has a surplus
of airbnb listings
we were just waking up every morning to
cancellation after cancellation after
cancellation
to help hosts cover cancellation costs
due to the pandemic
airbnb committed more than 250 million
dollars globally last year
in tokyo northcott says she received a
couple thousand dollars through airbnb
schemes
it would have been nice to have had more
support from airbnb
so for her business to survive she had
to pivot first
she targeted different types of
customers people who had to self-isolate
because they had traveled
or had been in contact with a coveted
patient this is the cleaning area we've
kept everything
based on the cdc guidelines there's
there's alcohol there's bleach
she also marketed her properties to
locals looking for staycations
we've got a ton of dvds then if you
wanted to work we put together a desk
that has a nice window fast wi-fi
northcott says this has helped her pay
some of the bills but she had to look
for long-term renters
broke leases and eventually got rid of
15 homes because she couldn't afford the
rent on the properties
they did send me a nice shirt though but
that's really been
about the only contact i've had with
airbnb
regarding the olympics the company
specifies in its terms of service that
hosts operate independently and have
complete discretion over their listings
helping host cities athletes and local
communities
airbnb still sees the olympics as a big
business opportunity
it has run a number of associated ads
and marketing campaigns
you know your logo as a brand is
potentially all over the stadiums and
all over the other olympic
co-branding opportunities so i think
that's a big public relations and an
advertising play
one of the biggest plays is a series of
digital experiences with olympic
athletes through the platform
users can sign up to hear stories
directly from their favorite athletes
or get personal tips on a training
routine to do something with character
and integrity
it's not an overnight success modi says
this kind of unique experience builds a
softer image of airbnb
which could help when dealing with
locals and regulators in markets have
been
tough to crack the credibility that you
gain from something like the olympics
helps you make that push when you're
lobbying government
and airbnb is in this for the long run
since its partnership with the
international olympic committee runs
until 2028
so modi says the strategy will play out
not only in tokyo
but also the next games in beijing and
paris
in paris where the mayor is really
trying to curb
airbnb airbnb is going to use this and
say look
you may want to be a little better
towards us because we're going to make
sure that you don't have an oversupply
in terms of visibility airbnb may still
benefit from its massive marketing
opportunity at the tokyo olympics
hosts like northcott say they're trying
to get through the pandemic and hope to
revive their business
in the future i'm a migrant i choose to
live here and i want to be
able to to show other people why it's
such a great place to live so i'm going
to keep giving it life support for as
long as i can